One of the reasons that high
road companies like Saturn
and others often
don't get carried on
is that once the founders leave,
the next generation of leaders
don't carry on the
same practices,
and so the culture goes back to
more traditional organizations.
But there are ways
to address this issue
by building commitments
to multiple stakeholders
right into the bylaws
of the corporation.
Let's look at some examples.
We'll consider three
different models.
First, let's talk about what
we call benefit corporations.
Benefit corporations build
right into their charter three
different objectives.
First, they say they
are going to commit
to producing results that are
good for their shareholders,
for their employees,
and for the economy.
Secondly, there are
going to consider
financial and non-financial
considerations when
making key decisions
that allow them
to keep the benefits flowing
to all of these stakeholders.
Third, they agree
to be transparent.
They provide annual reports
on their performance
and their progress in
addressing the interests
of these multiple organizations.
One of the best known companies
that is a benefit corporation
is Patagonia.
Patagonia is this very
famous clothing maker.
And its CEO and
founder, Yvon Chouinard,
says, Patagonia is trying
to build a company that
could last 100 years.
Benefit corporation legislation
creates the legal framework
to enable mission driven
companies like Patagonia
to stay mission driven through
succession, through raising
capital, through
changes in ownership.
In doing so it institutionalizes
the value, the culture,
the processes, and
the high standards
that are put in place
by these founders.
So by doing this we
get some continuity.
In fact, 22 states
now allow companies
to incorporate as
benefit corporations
within their boundaries.
And we have, at this point,
about 786 such companies.
Another option is
employee ownership.
You've probably heard the term
ESOP, employee stock ownership
programs.
Well, employee
ownership companies
build a commitment to being
successful financially
both for traditional investors
and for employee owners right
into the structure and
governance of the firm.
Employees often
have representatives
on the corporate
boards of directors,
but the key to success
of these companies
is to make employees feel
like owners by building
a culture of engagement, of
ownership, of encouraging
employees to make
suggestions for improving
the operations in
the performance
of the organization,
and therefore aligning
the incentives
through condensation
and through the culture
of the organization.
So employee ownership companies
have spread across the country.
There are about 10,000 of them.
And you can find them almost any
industry that you can think of.
The key to employee
ownership, though,
is to make sure
employees are involved,
and to also worry
a bit that they
don't to put all of
their financial resources
for retirement into
the same company.
You also want to
spread your investment
a bit so that you don't come
up short if the company happens
not to be as successful
as you would like.
There are other kinds of
companies call cooperatives.
A cooperative is
a company that has
lots of owners that pool their
resources to get some job they
all need done done together.
So if you happened
to grow up on a farm,
you may have been part
of a milk cooperative
where farmers pool
their resources
and create a dairy to take the
milk from their dairy cows.
There are sawmills in Oregon.
Here in Cambridge we have
the MIT coop and the Harvard
cooperative society, bookstores
that sell books and reference
material and clothing to our
students and to our faculty.
And then there's my
favorite cooperative,
as my tie suggests, it's
the Green Bay Packers.
Green Bay Packers are a
community own football
team started in the 1920s.
And how else could you have
a city, Green Bay, Wisconsin,
with only about
100,000 residents
sustain a very successful,
highly competitive, and often
championship football team
for all of these years?
It's because they are
owned by the community
and they can't be sold
to some higher bidder who
might make a profit off of it.
You'll also see
some cooperatives
in other countries.
Probably the most famous
one is the Mondragon set
of industries, headquartered
in the Basque region of Spain,
with companies that range
from manufacturing, to retail,
to high tech, to
financial institutions.
They have over 81 different
companies at the moment.
So we can build organizations
in different kinds of ways.
And so the takeaway
lesson that I
hope you will have here
from this conversation
is that it's possible.
If you are imaginative,
perhaps you
can invent the new
forms of organizations
for the future that will
meet the needs of all
of their stakeholders,
and will be built to last
for multiple generations.
And in doing so, not only might
you build organizations that
work for investors,
customers, and employees,
but maybe ones that help
to sustain our planet.